here I have a disc of wood with a hole  cut out of it now most people know an  object like this will tend to hang heavy  side down but check this out I'm going  to spin the disc and watch what happens  to the hole it goes to the bottom even  though it's lighter it goes down how  does that make any sense it's like the  center of mass of this disk is moving up  let's try it again just make sure it  wasn't a fluke  no the hole goes to the bottom the  lighter part goes to the bottom well let  me try spinning it with the lighter part  already at the bottom will it flip does  it just flip now this time the hole  stays there so the hole clearly wants to  be at the bottom while it's spinning but  why is that well I don't want to give  you the answer right away so make me a  video response and I'll pick the best  video response and I'll put it in my  explanation video so subscribe to find  out how this works